crazy when that happens it feels like
time has frozen it just stops you're
like and everybody laughs yeah it's
called a wedgie yeah a basketball wedgie
because it's wedged in between the rim
and the back he didn't know this morning
I didn't know I didn't I was trying to
act like I didn't be clear okay all
right but we begin this hour with what
else March Madness the NCAA tournament
is in full swing including Duke's 74-51
victory over Oral Roberts last night the
Blue Devils Big Win is nothing new but
the guy calling the shots is for the
first time in more than four decades
Duke has a fresh face leading the team
former Duke player John Shire CBS News
special correspondent James Brown
recently spoke to the new coach JB good
morning good morning Nate and team and
you know what while John Shire is a
fresh face leading the team make no
mistake about it he's no Duke newcomer
having played for his celebrated
predecessor Mike shazewski and by the
way he was an assistant coach under k
for nearly a decade we spoke by Zoom
before the tournament began Folk
focusing on what seemingly was an
unenviable task of filling the shoes of
a living legend
foreign
to the list of life's certainties death
and taxes you can add Duke's presence in
March Madness the Blue Devils are now in
their 45th NCAA tournament they've made
the final four in 17 of them and have
taken home all the glory five times for
every Championship Mike was head coach
but after 42 years running the program
Coach K is no longer in charge not only
is it a new era of Duke basketball but
it's really a new era of college
basketball guys like this it's coach
John shires team now as you thought
through this opportunity to take over
one of the toughest jobs to fill the
shoes of how did you deal with coming to
grips with that for yourself and the
expectation I've never been afraid of a
challenge and I understand what a
challenge this is uh I understand the
incredible expectations uh but at the
same time I think our program is set up
for amazing success let's have a great
one all right so far it's been a fairy
tale season for new coach Shire with 26
wins he's accomplished something not
even Coach K could you now are the
winningest first year coach at Duke so a
nice marker for the direction you're
heading in now beat up on me and tell me
you're not thinking about that at all go
ahead you set me up perfectly JB I'm
going to use after the year to reflect
and uh be proud of the accomplishments
right now focus on the next game and
making a special run here
how is that for pushing back was that
pretty good
though he'd never say so it almost seems
Shire was destined for this job from the
moment he met Coach K as a teenager you
told me that I was meant to do something
special I don't know if this is what you
had in mind when you said that
thank you
recruited out of his suburban Chicago
High School where he was known as the
Jewish Jordan Shire helped due to the
2010 National Championship and he's been
a member of the Blue Devils coaching
staff since 2014. all the while learning
from a master I don't know if anybody in
their right minds think that all right
I'm going to be the one to succeed Coach
K but of course when that opportunity
came about I was all in and Coach K
remains his mentor I love him he's he's
family to me and you know his support
means the world he's the best motivator
he is a field his ability to relate and
connect that's that's what separated him
and made him a special coach obviously
the X and O's and all that take care of
itself but but for me you know I pride
myself on relationships you know just
the connection with our guys you know
being able to get them ready to play to
believe in themselves for the highest
possible level that they can March
Madness is a little more than two weeks
of high stakes pressure and in a program
like Duke where expectations soar it's
not about making it to the tournament
it's about how far you go how will you
measure success you know for me it's all
about controlling what you can control I
promise my expectations are higher or as
high as anybody from the outside about
uh our success that we can have as far
as wins and losses in this program the
margin is thin the quote unquote little
plays that turn out to be the difference
in winning and losing and so for us
handling that the right way controlling
what we can control we'll put ourselves
in position to make a special run and
that's what it's all about for me
and you know that decisive and
impressive win last night can only
enhance shire's candidacy for the
national Coach of the Year award for the
best first time head coach up next for
Duke the volunteers of Tennessee now I
know I'm supposed to throw it back to
the table but I have to go to the best
athlete at the table no not Tony and
Nate who played but the former soccer
player Adriana Diaz Oh Me Maybe I was
looking around I was like who else is
here yes I played soccer in high school
2001 City champs for New York City Ghost
I was in high school yes thank you but
I'd love to that story about you know
coach K's successor and 42 years Coach K
was at the helm that's our lifetime I
also JB liked how he pushed back didn't
want to talk about his success that kind
of mental discipline you guys are
smiling and it's a joke and everything
but it's also serious part of the gift I
think of competing at that level is
being able to control what you're
thinking about to a greater extent than
the rest of us yeah and because Nate
played professionally Tony he would
certainly be able to speak to that but
that absolutely is a common thread for
those who are doing well not to get
caught up in the moment but to focus and
make certain you're making a kind of
progress that the team needs to make JB
you have sat down with so many
first-year head coaches across all
sports what was your biggest takeaway
when it comes to his disposition
you know what Nate he really is laser
focused he's internalized the
fundamentals because Nate you know most
people don't want to follow a legend
they prefer to follow the person who
follows a legend assuming that they're
not going to be doing well but this guy
is really zeroed in
all right JP thanks so much